Israel has freed a palestinian prisoner
who'd been on a 56-day hunger strike in
protest at his detention it's the tenth
time hudner Adnan had been detained
without charge by the Israelis we asked
london-based Palestinian journalists
Sharif and Nash hibi why he'd been
released I think his rods decision to
release him was more to do with the the
risk of upheaval if he died because
human rights groups have been
criticizing Israel's treatment of
Palestinian prisoners for many years and
that hasn't really had any effect on
Israeli policy towards Palestinian
prisoners so I think it was more to do
with with fears of the security
repercussions of him dying in prison
Adnan has consistently denied any
involvement in violence and the ten
times that he's been in prison he's not
been charging this is a fundamental
problem of Israel's prisoner policy is
that it can hold Palestinians
indefinitely without charge without due
process on the horrific conditions they
make accusations but if Israel has the
evidence to back up these accusations
then these prisoners should be charged
and should have a fair trial if a
certain party is not willing to be
transparent in its actions we cannot
take its allegations at face value there
are activists and militants out there
who are proud of their actions in their
involvement in whatever they do but he
has consistently denied involvement in
violence and without evidence to the
contrary then I don't think his word is
any less believable than Ezra it's
probably even more believable in the
absence that only evidence in the
confident the scale of Israel's
administrative detention policy is huge
and we have to remember that although
Adnan's release is currently being
celebrated in the occupied territories
there are several thousand palestinians
languishing in Israeli jails facing
terrible conditions that include torture
and these are long been highlighted by
international and Israeli human rights
groups so the scale of the issues should
not be forgotten amid the celebrations
of the release of any particular
prisoner particularly in light of the
fact that Israel has a revolving door
policy where it can release a prisoner
only to detain them once again on more
than one occasion this has to be borne
in mind this is not an Israeli
concession this is part of a very
problem of Israeli detection and
treatment of Palestinians without charge
without due process and severe
mistreatment which includes Palestinian
children one can very easily condemn the
kidnapping of people and also the
illegal imprisonment of people they're
not mutually exclusive so I don't think
by condemning Israel's attention policy
one can assume that that someone
supports the kidnapping of people both
are wrong but on the scale of things
Israel's detention of Palestinian
prisoners is a much larger issue this
issue long proceeds any kidnappings in
Gaza so while both are wrong we cannot
say well one is justified because the
other happens there they are both
condemnable